this is just a quick message for
everyone at roost to get behind and
support the world's greatest shave well
the Kamiya foundation does heaps and
heaps of good work in support of victims
who have suffered from this terrible
disease supporting their families and
also encouraging and funding research to
try and work out treatment and a cure
for this terrible ailment one of the
things that I've seen firsthand by
visiting the Children's Hospital is that
the people who suffer from leukemia are
people who number one need our help the
most because they're so young and also
number two are often incapable of
understanding what it is they're going
through and so they need our help all
the more can I also send a shout-out to
everyone who's actually shaving their
heads good on you is a fantastic thing
can I reassure you that you know when
you actually get your head shaved and
you're like is it really windy it's not
it's just the air moving past your head
which is now bold and can feel the air
you guys are doing a great job well done
and it's a really worthwhile thing that
you're making a sacrifice for lastly
even though I'm not getting my head
shaved this year I think it's a really
worthwhile thing to do so for everyone
who's thinking of supporting and hasn't
done it yet hasn't donated then he's a
bit of a sneak peek of what you're
actually giving money to and the kind of
suffering your friends are going to
incur when they get their head shaved
enjoy